An Italian artist is taking Easter to a whole new level...
His canvas is open land and his brushes are tractors.
For Holy Week, Dario Gambarin depicted a sacrificial lamb with the words "Happy Easter"...
...out on a field near the Italian city of Verona.
Covering a span of 27,000 square meters was no easy feat,...
...but it's actually his area of expertise.
Back in 2013, he also designed an image of Pope Francis shortly after his election,...
...with the phrase "Love liberates."
His list of designs also includes Nelson Mandela and even Barack Obama.
To begin, I make a sketch.
I try to find the essential lines of the face.
It's as if I'm cutting a piece of cloth to place on a paper.
Then I check out the feel on a tractor and try to find mental points of reference.
It's a unique skill that few people can master.
In fact, the only way he can check his work is through aerial photographs.
He learned how to drive a tractor as a child.
Now, he likes to combine his background with his unique, artistic skills.
It's not your average work of art, but it's sure to catch people's attention.